you can buy the 14 inch M1 Pro MacBook
Pro for 1400 on Amazon I'll link that
down below so does that mean that it's a
way better buy than the new 15-inch
MacBook Air well you guys keep asking
for us to make this comparison so here
you go I will focus mostly on
performance because you guys know the
exterior differences and I was honestly
surprised once I re-ran a bunch of tests
on the M1 Pro with software updates now
I do want to cover the physical
differences and mention that I really
enjoy the new 15-inch MacBook Air it is
a lot thinner and even though the weight
isn't much different 3.3 compared to 3.5
when you hold these things in your hand
it is crazy now typing is also more
comfortable on the 15 inch air because
of its thinness and its sleekness I
really really like it and with that it
doesn't seem like 14 inches compared to
15 as much of a difference but you guys
could see that the screen is is
noticeably larger because the main
surface area kind of stacks up when the
display is taller and wider now with
that said the 14 inch has a mini LED
display that can hit up to 1600 Peak
Nets so if you watch HDR movies music
videos it can be quite a difference now
when you're in normal lighting and
you're not watching HDR content it looks
identical and I don't have any
complaints of the 15 inch air it is a
great display the brightness levels
normally are the same but you notice a
difference if you're watching with the
lights off because the screen the blacks
are just gray instead of nice dark
blacks now Apple also upgraded the
speaker system in the 15 inch over the
13 we have six drivers and it is a
massive upgrade compared to that 13 inch
but because of the extra thickness of
the 14 inch they have bigger speaker
modules and it just sounds playing
better go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
now I will say that the 15 inch still
sounds great better than most other
laptops and you will be happy with it if
you don't compare it side by side where
the 14 inch it does give you a little
bit of a wow in certain movies and songs
Just because the depth of the bass that
you don't get now interestingly even
though both have 1080p webcams the 15
inch does actually look better it has
better processing so here's a little
clip for you guys now both these
MacBooks have 1080p webcams this one
right here is the 14 inch MacBook Pro
which has studio quality microphones and
this is the 15-inch MacBook Air now you
guys let me know which one looks better
and which microphones sound better to
you down in the comments and to me I do
notice that because the 15 inch is a
little bit taller the angle is actually
a little bit better but the quality
might be slightly worse so let me know
let me know what you thought about the
microphone quality as well because Apple
doesn't advertise studio quality on the
air but I still think it sounds really
good now as far as ports the 14 inch
gives you HDMI which is really nice you
also have an additional Thunderbolt port
and the SD card reader which I love and
I wish they put into the 15 inch here
now both have Max save charging but the
15 inch air actually comes with the fast
charger in the Box even at the base
price so you can hit 50 in 30 minutes
which is really nice whereas you have to
upgrade it if you get the base 14 inch
for that killer deal now as far as
battery life Apple advertises 17 hours
compared to 18 but that is actually when
you're just watching a local video it
actually goes down on the 14 inch for
web use but in our testing with mixed
real world use the MacBook Air is quite
ahead with 10 to 12 hours compared to
about seven to eight on the 14 inch so
paired with the fast charging it is
incredible I also made a low power mode
video going into how that works and with
the M2 Chip it works amazing with the
high efficiency cores we have four of
them compared to two worst ones and you
can actually get up to 20 hours of
battery life on the 15 inch air which is
amazing now getting into performance I
want to start out with the ssds because
we tested two 15-inch models the base
256 gig runs at around
1446 megabytes per second compared to
2900 if you upgrade to 512 and in our
117 gigabyte transfer test the
difference is way more than double
because the slower SSD actually slows
down when you're doing something like
this with that said the 14 inch Pros SSD
is still much faster at 4 800 megabytes
per second around there for read and
write so it is better now I also want to
mention other performance between a base
model you can get for 1200 bucks on
Amazon right now and upgrading the SSD
and the ram in Lightroom we went from
two minutes and 20 seconds down to a
minute and 17. almost double the
performance so if you are trying to
compare between buying a 14 inch or
buying this 15 inch well you obviously
care about performance so I'm going to
be focusing on the upgraded model
because if you care about perform
performance it is well worth that extra
price and that makes it even more
interesting because we're comparing 1700
bucks compared to 1400 that is a big
difference now in terms of single core
performance and geekbench the M2 beats
out the M1 Pro but in multi-core the 14
inch pro takes the lead but honestly by
very little I was surprised now because
of that for standard web browsing and
speedometer the MacBook Air smokes the 4
teenage so for most of your basic web
tasks the 15 inch air will be faster now
we also tested out figma which is a web
design app and this project is brought
To Us by 500 designs one of the best
studios in LA and zooming in and out it
was actually very close the 15-inch air
might have a slight leeway and then we
selected all 12 high resolution web
pages and we exported those and I was
surprised once again that the 15-inch
air did this faster a minute 48 compared
to a minute and 57 so if you're somebody
that does tough web-based activities
that can push your system the 15-inch
air is faster now in terms of graphics
performance this is where things start
to shift we have a difference of about
37 in favor of the 14 inch pro and in
Wildlife unlimited gaming test we have
55.5 compared to 41.3 uh 34 difference
now I'm another thing we have to mention
is thermal throttling because the 15
inch air does not have a fan which I
like because it is completely silent all
the time and it's so thin but looking at
cinebench R23 we have 7485 compared to
94.53 that's a difference of 26 after 10
minutes of maxing out the CPU then that
is just because it starts to slow down
now after the fact the 15 inch compared
to 13 it actually stays very stable so
it's not going to get worse and worse
which is great but what about some more
real life performance well for all of
you coders in xcode the air took 120
seconds compared to 111 for the Pro in
our xcode Benchmark and I was surprised
that the difference was that small and I
think the single core is definitely
helping out there on the M2 air so if
you're a coder well this thing is going
to be great because of the battery life
the screen and the performance is very
close now what is shocking is that in
the latest version of blender I was
exporting with both of these and the
MacBook Air actually beat out the M1 Pro
3 minutes and 57 seconds compared to 4
minutes and 24 seconds and of course
that is because of the upgraded
architecture and memory benefits of the
M2 Chip now this is a very tough project
already but if you're going to be doing
this all day of course we can get
throttling with the MacBook Air now in
Lightroom classic I exported 50 images
and the time was identical and I was
shocked because this used both the CPU
and the GPU and technically the 15 inch
air is slower but the M2 Chip does have
other memory optimizations better buffer
system and it definitely helped out here
now I mentioned slowing down previously
where it could throttle so this was 50
high resolution edited images but I also
did a test with 500 and instead of being
the same time well the difference was
between 12 minutes and 55 seconds all
the way up to 25 minutes and 35 seconds
yeah basically twice as long because
we're maxing out the CPU and the GPU so
the performance is fairly close unless
you're pushing it for a long time so
that should help you guys decide which
one you should buy now in terms of video
editing it's a little bit different
because the performance is basically the
same for most footage and the expert
times are also same 2 minutes 20 seconds
for a five minute 4K project and the
great thing is because of the media
engine that's built into the M2 Chip the
system doesn't heat up when you're
editing so that is awesome and then when
you're exporting you're also not maxing
things out so if you do basic video
editing the 15 inch is a killer option
with that larger screen as long as you
don't need HDR which this display makes
it a lot easier and better for that now
when you start pushing it more for
example prores we have a minute and 41
seconds compared to a minute and eight
so the M1 Pro even though it's an older
chip does still go ahead and then of
course if you're doing even harder raw
editing well then I just would not
recommend the 15 inch at all for that
purpose so with that said let's answer
the original question is the 14 inch M1
Pro refurbished for 1400 bucks a much
better buy than the 15 inch air well
technically yes it is better in most
cases it has more Hardware more features
better display and speakers but the 15
inch air is still such a nice laptop in
the form factor in the screen size gives
it a lot of extra points so unless you
have some of those tasks that really
require a Pro laptop I think you'll
still be very happy with the 15 inch
even though it doesn't make logical
sense as far as the bang for the buck
and the performance it is still an
amazing laptop and I prefer using this
over the 14 inch for almost all cases I
really like the 15 inch MacBook Air so
if you guys are going to pick it up go
ahead and check the links in the
description for a discount better price
on either one of these let me know your
thoughts click that Circle above to
subscribe and check out one of those
videos right over there at the spin Max
and I will see you in the next video
[Music]
all right